OH!
- OKAY.
- WE CAN DO IT!
PUT SOME GLUTE INTO IT!
- YEAH.
- HERE WE GO.
- OH, THIS IS COOL!
I'M GLAD WE DIDN'T CALL AAA
AND TOOK FATE
INTO OUR OWN HANDS LIKE CONAN.
OW, OW. I GOT IT.
ANCHOR.
- HOLY MOLY,
LOOK AT THIS CLASSIC.
- YEAH, SHE'S PRETTY,
GOT NICE LINES,
BUT NOTHING ON THE SWEDISH
MEATBALL HERE.
- YEAH.
- THAT IS AMERICAN MUSCLE.
THAT CAR FOUGHT IN VIETNAM.
- ALL RIGHT, MEN.
HERE'S MY CREDIT CARD.
GO GET SOME MAN SNACKS.
both: YEAH.
- PAY FOR THE BATTERY.
I'M GONNA GO, UH,
RAP WITH THE ENGINEER HERE.
SEE WHAT HE CAN TELL ME.
- YOU GOT IT.
- OH, GET SOME,
UH, BEEF JERKY.
BUT NOT THE PEPPERED.
I'VE GOT ACID REFLUX.
- WASH YOUR WINDOW
FOR $1.57.
- ARE YOU GONNA
BUY BEER WITH IT?
- NO.
- OH, WELL, THEN, I'M SORRY.
OUR MONEY'S ACTUALLY FOR BEER.
- I'M GONNA GET SCHNAPPS.
- YEAH, SCHNAPPS. COOL, COOL.
- YEAH. AWESOME.
- WE LOVE BOOZE TOO.
- A DOLLAR.
- OH, I DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY.
- NO CASH.
- DO YOU HAVE A CARD SWIPER?
'CAUSE I'LL GIVE YOU--
I'LL GIVE YOU,
LIKE, $1,000.
- NO.
- WE'LL LOOK
FOR A HAT FOR YOU.
- YEAH.
- WE'LL GET YOU A HAT.
- THAT'S WHY HOMELESS PEOPLE
SHOULD HAVE CARD SWIPERS.
- THEY SHOULD.
- I'D MAKE A GREAT
HOMELESS PERSON.
I'D JUST CARRY
A CARD SWIPER.
- THANKS A LOT, MIKE.
I'D TIP YOU, BUT MY BUDDY'S
GOT MY CREDIT CARD, SO.
- HEY-OH! AND THE SNACKSTERS
ARE BACK-DERS!
- WHOA.
- HOW WAS THE BATTERY SWAP
EDUCATIONAL?
- UH, HE DIDN'T
LET ME WATCH,
BUT HE'S GOT
A SUPER-COOL IGUANA INSIDE.
- WHAT?
- REALLY?
- YEAH, YOU SHOULD CHECK IT OUT.
- COOL.
- WHAT'D THE BATTERY RUN ME?
- MMM...
I DON'T KNOW.
IT WAS, LIKE, TWO,
OR THREE, OR--200 BU--
I THINK IT WAS,
LIKE, 100 BUCKS.
I DON'T KNOW, MONEY'S
NOT A THING TO ME ANYMORE.
'CAUSE I JUST
CHARGED TO THE GAME.
- YEAH, NOW WITH
THAT CREDIT CARD,
YOU CAN GET WHATEVER YOU WANT,
WHENEVER YOU WANT,
AND IT'S ALL, LIKE,
FREE, BASICALLY.
- YEAH, IT'S AWESOME.
- ALL RIGHT, GUYS,
ABOUT THE CREDIT CARD--
JUST A GUIDELINE--
- RIDE TO THE NORTH!
- YEAH!
- OKAY, GOING NORTH.
- IF YOU'RE A VIKING, AND YOU
SCREAM THAT WITH A BEARD,
THAT'S MANLY.
- WHOO!
- WAIT.
- OH, GRAB YOUR GUNS!
GRAB YOUR GUNS!
- OH, IS THIS--IS THIS
THE LITTLE GUY WE'RE GONNA GET?
- YEAH, WE'RE GONNA
KILL THIS DUDE.
- JUST GET YOUR... THING.
- HOLY MOLY,
SHE'S A THICK BITCH.
- SHE IS.
- A WORTHY ADVERSARY.
THAT'S WHY I'M GONNA STRING UP
AND GO FOR HER FIRST.
- YEAH, RIGHT, DERS.
FIRST COME, FIRST KILL, BUD.
- I DON'T KNOW, GUYS.
IT'S JUST A DUDE
DIVING IN A DUMPSTER.
WE'VE ALL BEEN THERE.
- BLAKE, IT'S CUTE.
IT'S A CUTE RACCOON.
DOESN'T MEAN
IT DOESN'T DESERVE TO DIE,
BECAUSE I'M A MAN.
- STOP SHAKING
AND TAKE THE SHOT.
- I'M NOT
NERVOUS RIGHT NOW.
- I DIDN'T SAY
YOU WERE NERVOUS.
- WELL, I'M NOT, THEN.
SHH, QUIET.
THERE'S ANIMALS.
[tribal drums and chanting]
- OH, HEY! HEY!
[tribal chanting]
[all screaming]
- OH, MY GOD!
- THAT WAS AWESOME!
- YOU SAVED MY GIRL CATCHER.
- WHAT?
- THAT'S WHAT I'M CALLING MY
FACE NOW--"THE GIRL CATCHER."
- HEY, CASSIE,
I GOT YOU SOME CORN NUTS.